The night sky is Spangled with countless stars.
Some of them are so staggeringly far,
that it would've taken the light from some of them thousands of years to reach
the earth. Others are comparatively close to us by space standards.
I've already told you about a few stars closest to our system in our previous
videos,
but there are other exciting objects among the immediate neighbors of our son.
Let's make our acquaintance with some of them
Cause Mo the first outer space,
there are only 1,400 stellar systems in space within the
radius of 50 light years from the solar system.
Some of them are multiple and contain two and more objects,
which makes the overall number of our stellar neighbors. Over 2000.
These are all sorts of stars from dim red dwarves to dazzling,
whose temperatures are beyond our imagination,
the incredible scale and great abundance of space objects in all their diversity
can't but amazing.
Life's too short to give a count of each and every one of them.
Right now,
we are going to travel at incredible speeds by far faster than the speed of
light. It will take us just a few minutes to cover dozens of light,
years of space.
We'll get to check out quite a few remarkable space objects around the solar
system. Other worlds and stars are already waiting
after we fly around Pima centi,
a detour of light years that would've passed in the blink of an eye where in the
environments of the dim red dwarf known as Ross 1 28,
we can't seed from the earth with a naked eye on preposessing though.
It may seem there is an earth like exoplanet dubbed Ross,
1 28 B orbiting. This star,
this exo planet is one of the closest to us.
Unlike the yet closer and cooler Pima,
centi B the temperature on Ross,
1 28 B is relatively moderate ranging from minus 60 to plus
21 degrees Celsius. Assuming it surfaced to be identical to that of our planet,
which absorbs 70% of the live shed on it. The equilibrium temperature of Ross,
1 28 B is estimated at around seven degrees Celsius.
It is eight degrees cooler than that of today's earth,
but quite enough to sustain life.
The exoplanets mass is roughly 35% bigger than that. The earth,
the radius hasn't been accurately measured at this point,
but provided that planet's composition is similar to our earths.
Its diameter is supposed to be roughly 10% bigger than that of the earth.
The free fall acceleration on its surface is expected to be just 12% bigger
than that in our planet. If all these estimations are correct,
then the conditions on the surface of Roon, two,
a B are supposed to be comparable with those on the earth.
Besides the system is rapidly moving to meet the sun in just
79,000 years, it will be closer to us than Proxima and Tory,
which is moving away from us quite like most exoplanets we know of
Ross. 1 28 B is located quite close to its host star.
The distance from it to the center of the system is just 0.05,
astronomical units or 20 times shorter than the distance between the earth and
the sun.
It takes the exoplanet slightly under 10 days to complete a full orbit around
its star. It has also thought that it must be ti locked.
Speaking about its host star Ross, one to eight,
its mass is approximately 17% that of the sun with the radius measuring around
0.2, that of the sun,
the Star's surface temperature is twice as low start of the sun at
3,192 Calvin and its luminosity is roughly
300 times lower than that of the sun.
It's worth mentioning that TRS one to eight is a comparatively quiet star with
its luminosity,
quite stable and regular it hardly ever flares up or emits Stella matter.
So niches for all living things,
moving all through space, 12 light years in the direction,
pointing away from the sun. We will see light in star,
also known as G 2 73.
It boasts one of the largest planetary systems detected in the space.
Nearest us.
The star itself is a red WARF of an orange hue whose mass is just
25%.
That of the sun its radius is three times smaller than that of the sun.
And its luminosity is 435 times lower.
So it's hardly surprising that it can only be seen through a telescope.
It is quite an exciting star because there is many as four Rob detected in
its environments. Two of which are confirmed exoplanets.
The other two are still prospective candidates, awaiting confirmation.
The first confirmed exoplanet was dubbed light and B.
It was detected thanks to high precision measurement of the stars,
proper motion.
The object mass is estimated to be about 2.8 times start of the earth.
Its radius is 35% bigger than that of our planet.
This makes the object a super earth and its surface gravity may turn out to be
suitable for humans.
The distance between the system center and light and B equals roughly 0.1
astronomical units.
Although the amount of light receive by the exoplanet from its parents star is
comparable with that received by us from the sun,
thus light and B lies in its Star's habitable zone and may well be considered a
potential candidate for searching for alien life.
The equilibrium surface temperature of the planet is 259 to
292 Calvin or minus 14 to plus 19 degrees
Celsius. This makes the conditions on light and B, why suitable for humans?
The other confirmed exer planet in the system is light and C with
this space objects are similar to that of the earth.
It lies much closer to its host star.
The exact parameters of its orbit haven't been defined yet,
but it is known that it takes the object just 4.7 days to complete a full
orbit around its system center.
It is likely that this is a scorching hot and harsh celestial body without any
atmosphere with one on the same side, facing the star at all times.
The two other objects in the system were discovered in 2019 and are still
awaiting confirmation of their status. According to preliminary estimates,
their rice giants with masses from five to 15 times,
start of the earth with the radi of the raw bits flying within point a eight
astronomical units,
their Rubal periods cannot be over 558 days.
Light is a relatively cold star.
And for these two objects lying beyond its habitable zone,
their temperatures are almost certainly extremely low.
It goes without saying that at this stage,
these two candidates still want further exploration
moving on and away from the lighting system where we come across a star known as
out air lying, 16.8 light years away from the earth.
It is a bright wide blue star.
Its mass is around 1.8 that of the sun and its age is estimated at
around 1.2 billion years.
This stars luminosity is 11 times outta the sun,
which makes it one of the most conspicuous objects in our night sky.
Another curious feature of out air is its rotation, which is remarkably fast.
Thus it spins on its axis approximately 67 times faster than
on. It completes a full rotation within slightly last than nine hours.
The velocity of star material of the equator equals about 286
kilometers per second. Due to this outstandingly rapid rotation,
the Star's shape is far from an ideal sphere.
The Star's equatorial diameter is 22% bigger than the distance between its
poles and is roughly twice the diameter of the sun.
The Stard shape can't but affect its temperature and luminosity,
which also differ in its different areas.
The stellar matter in the equatorial zone of the star is noticeably colder and
darker than in the poles. The temperature, the equator is just six,
900 Calvin. The poles meanwhile are as hot as 8,500 Calvin,
which is around 8,200 degrees Celsius.
Interestingly,
the fact that outter has an irregular shape was first arrived at following
theoretical calculations. Early later in 2007,
was it finally confirmed after an image of the star was produced where it has
seemed to have a disc like shape actually outer happened to become the first
star beyond the so system whose surface had been imaged
for no planet has been detected in out airs and VAs,
still observations show rings or a fog of gas developing the star
out airs light is dispersed in these structures,
which produces a curious effect.
This major interference of light results in a humongous rainbow around the star
on the downside. However,
even though it looks fascinating and majestic it partly conceals this style and
so greatly hampers studying it
as we carry on on our way through space,
we will get as far as formal out lying 25 light years away from the earth.
This Stella system consists of three component for a long time.
The three components making it up used to be considered mutually independent
space objects. Then in 2013, evidence showed that there,
in fact, gravitationally bound forming a large and single structure chain space
firm. How is probably the widest multiple star system located to ours?
The biggest distance between its components reaches 3.2 light years,
incidentally almost 11 lunar disks may be placed in our night sky between the
remotes objects in the formal how system the largest most well
known and well seen component of the system is referred to as formal.
How a it's a young and hot star whose mass is 92% bigger
than that of the sun with its radius measuring around 1.85 times that of
the sun. It was this star that people have referred to as formal.
How sens ancient times quite unaware of the fact that there are other not
so easily observable component in this system.
The stars luminosity is remarkably high. At 16 times start of the sun.
Its temperature is estimated at roughly 8,500 Calvin or
8,200 degrees Celsius firm,
or how could be as zone as 400 to 480 million years.
According to today's models of stellar evolution,
the star may grow to be around 1 billion years old on reaching the Sage.
It will more likely than not go supernova and turn into a wide dwarf.
Foal out a is surrounded by disc of pro to planetary gas and dust
divided into several segments.
Its inner radius is 133 astronomical units with a width
measuring about 25 astronomical units.
This disc is thought to be an active Stellan nursery with celestial bodies
regularly, born there.
That is why it is an area of keen interest for astronomies.
It used to be thought that there was a massive planet lurking somewhere in
informal house and environ.
It was even given a name Dagan however further
observations showed that there was hardly any planet there after all.
It must have been a wide CLA out of dust that was taken for an exoplanet.
It would've originated on collision of asteroids and comets
0.9 light years away from the main component of the system, their lies from,
or how to be also known as D w PIs or STR.
It's an orange war with a mass around 70% that of the sun with its radius,
roughly 63%, that of the sun,
the Star's surface temperature is estimated at approximately 4,700 Calvin,
which is 4,400 degrees Celsius. Interestingly,
the stars luminosity is much lower than that of the sun.
Our hosts star is five times brighter in 2019
on carrying out spectral and proper motion analysis scientists boot forward a
suggestion that there might be a celestial body as heavy as 0.6 to 1.9,
Jupiter masses orbiting the star.
The existence of this body still remains to be confirmed and its exact orbits
parameters calculated precisely.
And at this point preliminary estimations show that it should take the
hypothetical planet 25 years to complete a full orbit around its host star.
The third star, the firm Howard system is LP 8 76 dash 10.
It is a red dwarf flying two and a half light years away from the main component
to the system. The star five times lighter than the sun and its surface.
Temperature is slightly over 3,100 Calvin.
It takes LP 8, 7, 6, 10,
approximately 20 million years to complete a full orbit around firm or out a
apparently the red whaf would've orbited its big brother just 22 times since the
birth of the system as for planets or exoplanet candidates,
none of these have so far been detected near the star.
Still observations allow us to suppose that there is a cloud of gas and dust
around it. Whose radius is anything from 10 to 40 astronomical units.
Our next and final destination for today is 7.3 light years
away from the earth.
That's the distance we would've covered now to reach S the brightest star
in the Northern hemisphere and the fourth brightest star in the night sky.
The star is the main component of a binary star system.
It is an orange giant whose life is now slowly drawing to a close.
Most of its hydrogen has already been transformed into helium.
And now the star is busy burning the remains of its stellar fuel and gradually
expanding its size.
Aus is also the brightest star of a great stellar stream named in its honor.
This Gargan structure is in fact,
the debris of a dwarf galaxy absorbed by the Milky way.
Some 2 billion years ago, it contains 53 stars.
Most of them ode and dim and not nearly as impressive as S
emits 170 times as much luminous energy is the sun.
Although its surface temperature is much lower at just
4,251. Calvin.
It has thought that this giant used to be quite like our sun because its mass is
just 10% bigger.
But what were the inevitable depletion of its stellar fuel and the inner
pressure of its scorching hot plasma. The star turned into naing giant,
whose radius is now 25 times out of the sun.
According to today's theory of Stella evolution.
This is something that our sun is expected to go through in the distant future
too. Arch's age is gauged to 10,
from six to eight and half billion years.
It is hard to predict when it will go super over at the end of its lifecycle,
but it will happen quite soon in astronomical terms, shedding its out to layers,
Aus will become a scorching hot wide dwarf destined to slowly cool off in the
course of billions of years to follow.
The second component of the system is barely visible against background of it,
giant companion, this small star with luminosity 20 times lower than that,
of a lies.
So close to it that it's hardly possible to define its parameters.
Even if some planets did manage to form in this stellar system,
many millions of years ago,
they must have been absorbed by a itself either way.
No objects have been detected in the stars and environs at this point,
Having been closely observed by mankind for hundreds of years,
the universe is still a source of countless mysteries with such fascinating
objects, discovered close to our system. What may be lurking further,
say hundreds and thousands of light years away when observing the night sky
humans gaze barely brushes the closest stage of the great cosmos with its
forbidding mysterious and infinitely attractive expanses.
We're definitely looking to thousands of amazing new discoveries. Meanwhile,
feel free to hit the leg button, subscribe if you're still and dance. So,
and be on the lookout for more of our videos. Let's keep in touch.
I.